we're supposed to be out in the fields
we're supposed to be walking up hills
we're supposed to be looking for animals
or gathering vegetables
we're supposed to be doing all these
things that our body's designed to do
your genes have very little to do
with what's going to happen to you you
have to ask yourself
is my life worth trading
for that want to be happy build a life
not just a business
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one
challenge that is holding you back a
lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you
know there's something more inside you
you've got michael jordan level talent
at
something so today let's live your best
believe life and learn the six habits
that you need to stay
healthy
okay let's kick it off with habit number
one spend more time in nature with joe
rogan
one of the things that's causing this
funk that people are in is that we're
living our lives
many of us at least in these very
unfulfilling ways
where you're going to this office with
artificial light and you're doing
something you don't want to do
all day long and then you get home and
you're tired and on top of that you're
eating
you're eating potato chips and you're
drinking soda and your body is just like
what in the [ __ ] is this we're supposed
to be out in the fields
we're supposed to be walking up hills
we're supposed to be looking for animals
or gathering vegetables
we're supposed to be doing all these
things that our bodies designed to do
we're supposed to be in nature
and nature is like a medicine like it
literally is a medicine to you
people people that go you don't have to
go hunting you don't have to go fishing
just go
hike man just go hike up to the top of a
mountain and look out
you know there's a reward that you get
from that that is intensely like
soul filling there's like something
about like when i was in colorado
and there was this um this area of
boulder where you drive up one of these
roads and there's this area where you
could park
and it was this incredible view man
these people just park and just go out
there and just look
but you get there and you park and you
go
because you would see you're literally
seeing the continental divide
these snow-capped mountains in july yeah
in july it's covered with snow
because those mountains don't give up
habit number two acquire the right
eating habits with stephen gundry
what are some of the things you learned
through the process over the last couple
years that people were
people were finding out about themselves
and discovering about
other things you've got this new book
about living longer longevity paradox so
what were some of the things that you've
learned over the last couple years
about health in general with people so i
think one of the things that was
probably
one of the most controversial statements
in the plant paradox
was that it's your your bad health is
not your fault
it's your dna right it's your genes yeah
it's your genes and dna and
and i i go into a lot of this in the
longevity paradox
that in fact your genes
uh have very little to do with what's
going to happen to you
uh in both you know in the immediate
period
and in long term and there's a big
huge study looking at millions of people
around the world
uh and their outcome looking at their
genetics their dna and their dna
has only probably about a six percent
influence on you your health
what's going to happen to you so that
means including like diseases
so why do we always when we go to the
doctor they say well did your father
have a stroke or a heart attack did your
mother have
dementia so when when i ask that
question
and i do what that tells me is
that if your you know
mother had diabetes or your father had
coronary artery disease that tells me
that if you eat like your
parents did then you will
most likely have those diseases not
because you
inherited that from your parents but you
learn to eat from your parents and it
actually goes beyond that
not only did you learn to eat from your
parents but
you shared the microbiome the bugs
in your gut that your parents had in
fact
as we talked about in the book you can
take
identical twins and raise them
apart and they will actually
have microbiomes more in common
with the family that they were raised
with
than their identical twin and the
outcome
health outcomes of those identical twins
will not
parallel genetics they will parallel the
microbiome
that they acquired interesting living
with that other family so you could be
separate from your twin for whatever 15
20 years
live in different uh live with different
i guess health benefits and and one more
than the other
see each other and almost look different
yeah that's exactly right and you can
actually
you know there have been some studies of
twins who have been raised apart
and clearly they're identical but
depending on how they ate and their
microbiome that they acquired
they can look quite different habit
number three
respect your life with john ashraf
people have to
make a decision what they want to trade
their life for yes
because every day we're trading our life
for the people that we
associate with for the business or job
that we have
you know for what we eat for the health
for the enjoyment for the fun for the
experiences
and you have to ask yourself is my life
worth trading for that
if it's not today is a good day to stop
i love that right yeah but most people
don't think that they're trading their
life
you know for something they think that
you know oh there's tomorrow and there's
next week really
well i have you know evidence to prove
otherwise
that we have no idea you know when the
last breath will be
yeah so let's trade our life every day
as it's the most important thing
in the world and not from an ego
perspective
from uh from a humble grateful
perspective of wow i get
another day to live and to enjoy be
grateful
grateful for that but then to respect it
see respecting your life means you're
going to trade it
for things that you feel are worthy
of it most people you know ask
themselves the wrong question
they ask themselves you know am i worthy
of the goal and the dream that i have
and they should be asking themselves is
that goal that dream that i have
worthy of my life change the question
and if you say yeah i'll trade my life
for that good then go and do that
hey this is john asref and do you love
good books i love to read because
there's so much
wisdom in books you get to take somebody
else's knowledge
skills research pay 15 20 bucks
and you learn so much now i'm reading
this
awesome book called built to serve find
your purpose and become the leader you
were born to be
and one of my new friends really smart
guy
really great guy who serves a lot of
people evan carmichael
wrote it and um i'm going to read a
little bit from
chapter number one and
i love this piece and maybe it's because
i just watched
the series on tv on michael jordan the
last dance which is really great by the
way also
one of the things he says here is
everybody has
michael jordan talent
at something everybody has a michael
jordan talent at something
you just haven't found it yet or you
have and you don't
believe in yourself enough to go
all in to go all in right
and you're a genius i believe you're a
genius and so does he
you're amazing you were not meant to
live a photocopy
of someone else's life you were not
created to wake up and do work that is
below your capabilities you have michael
jordan level talent at something
and you need to uncover exactly what
your purpose is
and how you can serve and use the serve
so
lots of pearls and gems and motivational
pieces
pickup built to serve evan carmichael
rising star hobbit number four set and
eating cut off time with oprah winfrey
the single thing that helped me the most
uh to click was not eating past
7 30. now depending on what time you go
to bed
i'm you're looking at that i mean not
eating
a grape not a grape not a rice or a
crispy
past 7 30. and the thing about it is i
started it at seven o'clock and then
just i was killing myself trying to get
home oh
7 26 i gotta get home
for a lot of people who making bad food
choices if you just
do that that will turn there's a lot of
magic in that yeah it's real
it's magical if this just it's just like
just like you brush your teeth you say
7 30 i do not eat past 7 30. and
the farther up you can move that the
better you get now this is the key this
is what really
saved me i remember you told me this day
we were walking around and i went
why the hell you wait 10 years to tell
me that
okay bob said to me when you cut off
your eating
you cut off your eating at least two to
three hours before you go to bed he goes
that little gnawing feeling you get that
little gnawing where you feel like
i feel like i need to eat something he
said that is when you are going into
your fat
stores and you can either feed that
feeling
give it food or you can say oh this is
when my body is going into my
fat stores and it's going to now eat the
stored
fat that's what that feeling is and so
what happens with most of us we try to
feed that feeling
and then you wake up and you're you
you're back you're fat
so what you're what you really want to
look for is that little
that it took 10 years he was telling me
that we're walking along i go you mean
that's it that's it that little thing
that says
i want to eat something not i'm starving
but i wish
and most of us what you do is you go to
the cabinet you open the cabinets and
you start grazing you kind of go down
this is what i've done before you say is
it rice krispies no
is it oh maybe some chocolate no let me
try
have a pork chop no that wasn't it
but that's what you want you want to
feel like when you go to bed at night
you want to feel like
i wish i could eat a little something
and that's the moment when your body's
going we're going to go
into your butt now
you're going to pull some up out of the
thighs
habit number five get rid of stress with
joe dispenser
as i said seventy percent of the time
people live in stress and living in
stress is living in survival now
all organisms in nature can tolerate
short-term stress you know
a deer gets chased by a pack of coyotes
when it outruns the coyotes
it goes back to grazing and the event is
over and the definition of stress is
when your brain and body are knocked out
of balance out of homeostasis
the stress response is what the body
innately does to return itself back to
order
so you're driving down the road someone
cuts you off you jam on the brakes you
may
you give them the finger and then you
settle back down and the event is over
and boom
now everything's back back to normal but
what if it's not a predator that's
waiting for you
outside the cave but what if it's your
co-worker
sitting right next to you and all day
long you're turning on those chemicals
because they're pushing all your
emotional buttons
when you turn on the stress response and
you can't turn it off
now you're headed for disease because no
organism in nature can live in emergency
mode for that
extended period of time it's a
scientific fact
that the hormones of stress down
regulate genes and create disease
long-term effects
human beings because of the size of the
neocortex we can turn on the stress
response just by thought alone we can
think about our problems and turn on
those chemicals
that means then our thoughts
could make us sick so if it's possible
that our thoughts could make us sick is
it possible then our thoughts could make
us well
the answer is absolutely yes so then
what are the emotions that are connected
to survival let's name them
anger aggression hostility hatred
competition fear anxiety worry
pain suffering guilt shame unworthiness
envy jealousy those are all created by
the hormones of stress and
and psychology calls them normal human
states of consciousness i call those
altered states of consciousness so then
we tend to remember those traumatic
events more because in survival
you better be ready if it happens again
that's and and when survival gene is
switched on you could have 10 really
great things that happen to you in your
day
and you just have one bad thing that
happens and you cannot
take your attention off that bad that
that unhappy thing because
the survival gene is switched on inhabit
number six the last one before a very
special bonus habit is
take cold showers today's challenge
is to take a cold shower and you're like
i was loving this guy
until he said cold shower i hate cold
showers
now why let me talk about why because i
don't like cold period i don't like cold
baths cold showers
cold environments but cold could be your
teacher
many of you listen to great avail to uh
with great response
to our episode with wim hof i met wim
over six years ago wim hof is the ice
man if you haven't listened to that
episode
please where he talks about cold is my
teacher where he climbs the
himalayas in his underwear and he swam
underneath the arctic
amazing amazing man but it talks about
the power of
cold and if you listen to also my
episode on my morning routine you know
one of the things i do every morning
is i take a cold shower or an ice bath
here so there are a number of reasons
why you want to take a cold shower
and starting with number one it lowers
inflammation
it lowers inflammation so one of the
challenges to your brain
which also is part of your body are high
inflammation levels
and if you listen to our morning routine
we do things like have turmeric
turmeric tea and such which sounds
really good right after you take a cold
shower
by the way cold reduces inflammation
it's like you
you bang your knee on a coffee table
what do you do you put ice on it to
reduce swelling inflammation
but we also have inflammation in our
body so cold is very powerful with that
again listen to the episode we did
with wim hof the ice man he's an expert
at that because he lives his talk he
actually does it
the second reason why you want to take a
cold shower in the morning i don't go
through specifics on how long and such
the second reason is because it's like a
nervous system reset
for me it's better than coffee when i go
into the cold
i feel like after when i come out of it
it's like i'm brand new and
you can attest to this have you ever
gone into a cold lake before
or just like when you go out in the cold
you come in and you're like you feel
refreshed
it helps to reset your nervous system
the third reason why you do it though
is because you want to get yourself to
do difficult things especially as part
of your morning routine
you get yourself to do difficult things
and that's what's important here
part of the reason we're doing this
quick brain challenge is we know that
challenge leads to real
change when you challenge yourself
through struggle your struggle
by overcoming that struggle becomes a
strength or
if you will a super power and so what
are you doing you're
testing your ability to be able to deal
with what's uncomfortable
and as we talk about if you're just
doing the easy things
put things off procrastinate then life
is difficult if you do the easy things
life becomes difficult
but if you do the difficult things you
get yourself to do difficult things you
build your grit
muscles if you will then it's going to
show up in a life that becomes
easier you know what i mean like when
you're doing difficult things you have
that difficult conversation with
somebody
you get yourself to work out you get all
the benefits of having an easier life
because
life is not necessarily easier it's just
you are better
and so when you're putting yourself in
uncomfortable situations like a cold
shower a cold bath
some of you do a cryotherapy where
you're in a what is it negative
230 degrees for two and a half minutes
obviously consult with your healthcare
practitioner you're putting yourself in
in a safe way in an uncomfortable
situation so you're building that
ability that fitness if you will to be
able to show up and
speak in public if you have a fear of
public speaking or to have that meeting
or
to ask for that sale if you're an
entrepreneur or to do the thing as a
parent that you need to do that you've
been putting off
so again you're building your grit so
again reasons why you want to take all
shower
number one lowers inflammation number
two it's like a big nervous system
reset which is great for your brain and
the third reason
you're training yourself first thing in
the morning to do difficult things
so there's a science to momentum and you
get yourself to do difficult things
and then when you get to work doing that
difficult thing that you've been putting
off because i do believe
that the treasure you seek is found it's
hidden in the tasks you are avoiding
so as you're getting yourself in the
habit of creating new habits
because that's what we're doing with
this challenge you're going to do it
today or tomorrow the next time you take
a shower
now what specifically are you doing you
want to build your way up to it i'm not
saying take a
two minute cold shower because it's cold
it's uncomfortable
so baby steps right every pro was once
an amateur
and so every every every expert was once
a beginner so you go in and you just do
10 seconds
maybe you do 10 seconds on 10 seconds
off and also their health benefits going
from cold to hot
if you've gone to some of the spas they
have a cold plunge and then like a
heated jacuzzi so it increases your
vascularity
and so it's building that pump if you
will so go maybe 10 seconds cold
10 seconds hot warmer 10 seconds cold 10
seconds hot and you can build yourself
i do my box breathing my alpha breathing
my fire breathing my wim hof breathing
and i push myself in a healthy safe way
now i have a special bonus habit on how
to get more quality
sleep that i think you're gonna enjoy
but before that it's time for the
question of the day i wanna know from
the six habits we've talked about today
which one do you need to most apply to
your life right now
let me know put it down in the comments
below and if you made it this far in a
video you're still here watching i want
to celebrate you because believe nation
we don't just watch videos we do
something about it so that's you and you
commit you promise you're going to take
action
immediately after watching this video
give me a hashtag believe down in the
comments and tell me where you're from
because i want to celebrate you so i
usually
go to sleep around midnight
uh and i usually wake up around 7 30
7 7 30 somewhere in there um
that's a typical day it gets thrown
around every now and then but that's
that's kind of typical for me
okay so as an entrepreneur right with
like a crazy schedule because i know
you're on such a schedule like you have
your set days on
when you produce episodes when you do
your
you know public appearances right like
with you know blab
and just go on other people's podcast
it's like how do you manage all that and
how do you manage to really get enough
sleep with all that crazy schedule
yeah and i have an added thing where i
have a really weak immune immune system
like if i don't sleep
seven hours consistently at least i get
sick
if i go two days in a row of bad sleep
i'm sick
uh i'm just it's you got a phone call
there bro yeah
it's supposed to be a mute uh
yeah i get sick like and for people
who've been watching my channel
uh there's a lot of videos where i'm
sick
and it's often because of like either
lack of sleep or just
you know at the dance studio there's
always lots of people and you know
you catch viruses um
so i need sleep if i if i don't get
sleep one night the next night has to be
solid or i know i'm gonna be up
so how do you ensure that you get that
you get your seven hours in
yeah so a couple couple things i think
some of them are basics that you
probably heard before
you know try to keep to the same time uh
try not to eat like a heavy meal before
going to sleep because at least that
keeps me up uh
i'm super sensitive to light so i i have
a mask on that that
you know like if i travel i forget my
mask i'm having terrible sleep
um but some other things that may be a
little different than what most people
are doing
um one we have no electronics in the
bedroom
so there's no cell phone or bedroom
there's no ipad in the bedroom there's
there's nothing with a light you know
like if people stay up and read that
like blue screen and that just keeps you
awake
and so our phones are plugged in uh
outside the room and so my wife has an
alarm in the morning she's gonna get up
out of bed to go turn it off there's
nothing electronic
in the room um so that one helps because
before we're
kind of sitting in bed next to each
other before we pass out
and i think one it also kind of gives
you a little more connection because
there's
there's nothing to read so you talk to
yourself right
but i think you know you get so
distracted by emails and news and stuff
so
so no electronics in the room uh and
that's that's helped both of us
i think sleep um two
is when i get an idea
i go and take care of it uh so i'll get
out of bed sometimes you go to bed with
with an idea like oh
you know i got a great idea for julian's
dance studio man and then
and then you lie in bed trying to forget
it and and you know wrestling with it
and for me it'll keep me up all night
and
uh and i'm gonna worry that i'm gonna
forget it because i don't have a great
memory if i don't write it down it's
gone
and so i will get up and send that email
off
to julian to tell him about what he
needs to do for his dane studio
uh or whoever it is and then it's like
it's released because otherwise it stays
with me and i have a terrible sleep and
so
i'm not afraid to get up and out to
solve whatever is kind of that
that monkey in my head i need to release
it um
having a routine to help you wind down i
find super helpful
so just like you know when you're a kid
you have
you have a routine that your parents
give you right like you have a bath and
you brush your teeth and you get a
bedtime story and like
you get used to that yeah uh routine and
then that helps
you like oh your body starts to shut
down right
uh and then we kind of lose a lot of
that when we get
into adulthood and it's it's i used to
find it really hard like i come back
from
my salsa studio after a great night
and and i'd be wired like talking to
people and i just can't go
to sleep right away and so i need to
create a schedule
a little routine to uh to decompress a
little bit
uh and so whatever it is for you it's
great for me we start by i light a
candle
so we have a candle since we don't have
electronics in the room we also turn up
the lights so light a candle
um that's on my wife's side and that's
how i start you know i'll then open up
the bed and like
make space for both of us and then go
and like brush my teeth and
just read some news to like decompress
get my mind off business
um you know floss wash my face
go to bed do some cuddling and then go
to sleep and so it's like the same
thing every night and then as soon as i
go to the bedroom to turn on the candles
i start weighing down decompressing
winding down
and then i start getting tired and after
like the 15-20 minutes of taking to
everything else then
i'm ready to go to sleep um so having
that kind of routine whatever it is for
you
i find helps
[Music]
if you want even more habits to keep you
healthy check out the video right there
next to me i think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there it's really important for us to
take on a learning role and say i am
creating
this situation and i can uncreate this
situation